schooling is by the universal and you
can do about you know I do okay so
thanks a lot for the invitation and
chance to speak so it's sort of a
continuation of what's been going on
this morning in terms of polar models
and cluster expansions what I'm gonna
talk about is doing work with will
Perkins
this is sort of the the thing that will
pointed to in the morning is being the
first paper that sort of started off
some of these ideas as you can see from
this slide it's it's a subset of z2 and
they're sort of two sets of people there
are people where you say choose your
favorite graph and they immediately say
ZD and refused to consider any other
graph and that's someone like me and
then there's most of the other people in
the audience here but this talk is just
going to be about ZD so the motivation
is very similar to the animations that
we'll show at the beginning of his talk
for the plots model but in case you
didn't see those I'm gonna consider the
hard core model instead and I just want
to know what does an independent set
look like on the hard core model as I
vary the activity parameter so if
lambdas very small I don't see very many
particles so the picture looks something
like this in a little square and z2 well
if lambda is very large then we start to
sort of fill up the volume quite a bit
something that looks roughly like this
so there's there's no animation of
showing you the difference in behavior
between these two extremes of lambda but
we know this sort of four independent
sets which we've talked about a lot
during this workshop that as I get full
we sort of know what things are going to
look like so just to fix some notation
for how I'm talking about independent
sets this is the partition function that
I'm interested in it's going to be a sum
over all independent sets on my graph
lambda lambda to this game
so the probability of any independent
set is just proportional to the weight
it received in here normalized by C and
this fact that there's two different
pictures is you know was first sort of
made a rigorous thing by dilution said
that if the dimension is at least two
remember I'm only talking about the ZD
so D is the dimension not that degree
anymore then there exists a phase
transition
so I'm not going to use this anymore so
maybe I can shut the distracting
animated gif
so let me just make me make this a
little more precise what it means that
there's a phase transition
so to do that I'm gonna let J be an
independent set on all of Z D and I'm
going to define a new partition function
that has J as its boundary condition so
what that means is that now I'm going to
sum over all independent sets again in
ZD that are the same as J outside of
lambda and then I just take lambda to
the size of the independent set
intersect the set lambda so it's just
counting the number of particles lambdas
some finite connected subgraph of ZD so
like like my box so as long as it's a
finite region this is a well-defined
object so if I if I do this what I get
is I got a collection of probability
measures that are going to be indexed by
the set in ZD and also by the possible
boundary conditions so I get a set
this and the precise thing that the
bouche improved is that its land is very
small exists a unique week limit of this
set of probability measures and it flam
this very large exists at least two
limits in particular the measures I get
if I consider the even boundary
condition and the odd boundary condition
are different so I'm using E and O to
denote the independent set that just
occupies all the even vertices or just
occupies all the odd vertices so we have
a very precise idea of what an
independent set looks like in the sense
of knowing that there's a phase
transition but we could ask a much
stronger question that people here would
naturally ask how to use sample one of
these objects so sampling or what does
one look like not just in an asymptotic
probabilistic sense about weak limits
but what does one look like intensive
seeing a picture of one
so what's knowing you know the most
natural thing that you could do is use
glabra dynamics to try and simulate this
like we'll was showing for the Potts
model and if lambdas very very small
then clobber works
so that was known a long time ago I'm
someone here probably knows who did it
first I'm not totally sure to be honest
and there's been a lot of work about
improving lambda very small to trying to
get more optimal values of lambda but I
don't have time to go into that story as
you can imagine the density is very high
then the global dynamics fail so I think
the first example of a phenomena
somewhat like this was probably from
Lawrence Thomas and then later on many
people contributed to this story
including like Prasad and other people
in this room as well so our goal and I
mean both in the sense of for this talk
and also our goal when we started doing
this work was to say how do we turn our
probabilistic understanding into
algorithms to approximate the partition
function and sample here
and maybe I could say the goal is to
turn probability into algorithms and
fortunately for the sake of this talk we
succeeded
and the theorem we proved is the
following thing so there exists some
density that depends on the dimension
that if you're above that density then
there exists an FP test for the
partition function and the O lambda for
lambda contained in ZD finite and
connected we did a little more than that
you can also sample and another thing
that you might want to do
so also you can do the Taurus provided
that n is even and the error you want to
make is at least e to the minus C or C
is some constant that depends on the
dimension okay so in all these contexts
we can approximate the partition
function and we can sample and we did it
involves this thing called pure gobs
tonight theory and I'm going to talk
about that right away it's much more
general than for the hard core model
though so the same theorem is true if
you consider the Potts model the same
theorem is true if you consider the
Widom Burlinson model most of your
favorite discrete statistical mechanics
models fall under this framework and you
get sampling and counting algorithms by
verifying just a few conditions how
about free boundary so free boundaries
would be okay I believe but we didn't
check every last delta of the proof but
I will not use clobber clobber fails so
so clobber provably doesn't work so we
must do something else and in this
theorem it's a it's a deterministic
algorithm it's not a randomized
algorithm any other questions before I
yes
Oh in this case it's just you could if
you could come up with a definition
about being on one side means or you
could just compute the true partition
function so that's the thing you would
want to compute but of course you do it
by reducing to the mostly even and
mostly odd okay so what I just said
quickly in words maybe let me write down
many discrete document
so it applies to many discrete
statistical mechanical models provided
symmetric phase so there's some
restriction that you have to satisfy and
what this means they have to be at this
symmetric part of the phase diagram and
I expect that phrase means almost
nothing to everyone here so I'll explain
what that means next as a way of
introducing paragraphs tonight theory so
the next part of the talk is me telling
you what paragraphs in I theory is and
after that I'll show you how we sort of
reduce our problem into that framework
so roughly speaking paragraphs tonight
theory is a sophisticated cluster
expansion or a sophisticated polymer
model like we'll was talking about and
to illustrate the idea let's consider
the Q equals 3 Potts model for me I want
to write it the energy of a
configuration is I sum over all vertices
in the graph and I tech check when the
color at the vertex I and the vertex J
is the same and I add an additional term
that sort of favors one color or the
other
according to some parameter H so the
probability of a configuration if beta
is very large this is a low temperature
scenario and if beta is small it's not
and these sort of break the symmetry
between the various colors so the
important definition is of a ground
state it's really this is a periodic
ground state so this is a coloring
that's periodic
such that for any finite perturbation
this just means another coloring that
only differs from Sigma in finitely many
coordinates
I only decrease the energy
so particular examples of this if all of
the HS are zero then just taking all of
the colours to be the same everywhere
so I'll just color one just color two
and so on those are periodic ground
states and you call the ground state
stable if you know that the limit as
lambda increases to ZD the energy of the
configuration restricted to lambda is
maximal okay so what does this mean in a
concrete example suppose only H one is
positive and the other HS are zero so
then I'm assigning more weight to the
color one so then the stable ground
state is going to be coloring everything
one while ground states two and three
will not be stable
does that make sense before I draw a
picture of what it means so we usually
organize that information into a phase
diagram so this is at zero temperature
so beta equals infinity just by
normalizing I can choose H 1 to be 1
this is the H 2 axis this is H 3 so now
I'm just going to label these regions by
which ground states are stable so in
here it's 1 and here it's 2 and here
it's 3 along this line I have two stable
ground States so they're said to be one
to coexistence here there's two and
three here there's one and three and
then at this point one two and three are
all stable so this is sort of the
symmetric point of the phase diagram
so what is pure Goths tonight theory
well what it says is that if beta is
very large this picture is still true
I shouldn't say picture is a phase
diagram
it's still correct up to small
perturbations of the curves
so at zero temperature this problem is
easy or not so difficult to determine
what the stable ground states are and
what this theory tells you is that beta
is very large the picture remains true
in the sense that you can determine all
of the extremal periodic Gibbs measures
so these limiting objects of this
collection are called Gibbs measures
this is not maybe the best the canonical
language that we usually use to describe
all the cubes measures but it's an
appropriate one so you ask what are the
extreme mode gives measures and you get
this picture so if you've chosen the
parameters H to let you're in this
region there'll only be one extreme will
Gibbs measure well if you choose the
parameters that you lie on this curve
there'll be two extreme
so this this theory is really a set of
tools it's a method it's not a theorem
that you just plug in and get this
conclusion in any given case you have to
do a bit of work and it's actually a
very powerful method it tells you much
stronger information so another thing
that you can learn that might be of
interest to people in this workshop so
you can learn that the zeros so as a
function of the H eyes or the hrs lie on
the coexistence curse
so when we were talking about the li
yang theorem at various points in this
workshop we were thinking about the
zeroes as functions of the external
field that's what these HS are is the
external field parameters and Pirogov so
nine theory is powerful enough to tell
you that when you're in this low
temperature regime you actually know
where the complex zeros of the partition
function are you have to choose the
parameters that you lie extremely close
to these phase coexistence curves in
finite volume and as the Box gets bigger
and bigger the zeros
well you'll only see zeros of the
partition function complex zeros except
in the coexistence regime here so
paragraphs a9 Theory goes back to the
70s and this is much more recent this is
maybe like mid 2000s or so but it's all
part of the same philosophical approach
to studying the phase diagram by
paragraph so nine theory
okay so
so now is a good time if there's any
questions about what a phase diagram
means or what Paragons tonight theory
does that you asked me because I want to
spend the rest of the time sort of
explaining how you use this idea to
study high density hardcore modeling on
CD okay so
so we only use a small fraction
but because of connections like these
complex zeros conceivably you can answer
much more detailed questions and there
are many interesting applications I
would expect of paragraphs in I theory
two questions of interest in computer
science so the part that we use is how
to convert questions into polymer model
questions
so we'll spend 25 minutes saying how do
you actually do counting and how do you
do sampling once you have a polymer
model where you can prove the cluster
expansion converges so what I'm going to
show you is how to set up a polar mode
where it's possible to prove convergence
and then the rest of the story is more
or less the same as well described so
step 0 is that we want the polymers to
represent deviations from the thing we
expect to see so we should rewrite the
partition function in a way that makes
that possible so the first thing to do
let me just focus on choosing the even
boundary condition for the sake of
choosing one so I take out the
contribution from the maximal
independent sets maybe they have size m
and then what remains I have to put in 1
over lambda and just that I don't have
to keep rewriting 1 over lambda all the
time I'm gonna make little Z lambda
inverse and Z lambda of Z so once I do
this we have the lowest order
coefficient of this polynomial is the
number of maximal independent sets sorry
the number of maximum independent sets
the ones with the highest cardinality
and the coefficients of Z are the
smallest perturbations
we're just sort of getting us in the
direction of having some kind of
systemic polymer model representation
but the the challenge of the method is
basically to formalize the idea that the
low order terms in Z are actually
representing small perturbations and
proving that they're small
that's what convergence of the cluster
expansion means so let's see how to do
that
so step one let you fix some independent
set I and you fix some just pics on
vertex V in your graph you call me
correct you see one of the two local
pictures that I'm about to draw so if
it's correct it should look like a
ground state the ground states are all
even are all odd for the independent set
model so either I should see that V is
occupied its nearest neighbors are
unoccupied and its next nearest
neighbors are occupied or if V is
unoccupied all of its nearest neighbors
should be occupied and none of its next
nearest neighbors should be occupied so
if you see one of these two pictures V
is correct for the independent set I and
otherwise its else otherwise it's
incorrect
so using this idea of having correct and
incorrect vertices we can start to draw
pictures that are easier to draw than to
write the explicit expressions for the
partition function that get us close to
a polymer model so we have connected
components of incorrect vertices let's
draw a picture for simplicity let's
choose a nice subset of ZD like a box
and we have even boundary conditions all
the way around and I have some
connecting components of incorrect
things so schematically get something
like this
so all of the shaded region is
indicating incorrect of course inside of
some incorrect region I could see some
correct regions again so I might have
holes and inside of those correct
regions they might have incorrect
regions again so there might be some
more things here and continue on and on
forever well not forever cuz it's a
finite graph but you know a long time
you know this happens if you look at
maps too you can check on Wikipedia for
the most islands within a lake or it's
right yeah islands were going to like
within an island within a lake and I
think in Canada somewhere there's like a
depth 7 chance okay so this is looking
kind of like a polymer model
I'd like the things that are going to be
polymers to be subsets gamma and I want
to label them with the configuration on
the subset so these are the connected
components the configuration there's
just a little problem here if this is
even and this is correct then I know the
boundary of this is also even and the
boundary of this is even and the
boundary of this is even this is correct
so it must be even or odd maybe this one
is odd and maybe this one is even if
this is even that means the exterior of
this incorrect chunk and this incorrect
chunk are both even
so these have matching external labels
that seems innocuous but it's really bad
for the polymer model representation
because the condition of being a polymer
model was that things are just
geometrically disjoint and this is a
long-range interaction it doesn't matter
how far apart these two components are
they still interact as one another by
the condition that they have the same
exterior label so this thing is not a
polymer model so we have to do a little
more work so that's step two so we do is
that we group
the collection of independent sets on
lambda into equivalence classes
and the equivalence classes are
determined by some of the objects in
this picture so by they're determined by
the external
so the external collections of gamma
so what does it mean to be an external
object it means that if I start inside
my connecting component I can go to the
boundary without passing through any
other component so this is a
well-defined notion so I pick an
independent set I get some collection of
external contours and then I sum over
all of the independent sets that would
give me the same set of external
contours and if you do that what you get
is that the partition function be
written as sum over collections of
mutually disjoint and external
with label then you have to take the
weight of all of these things so you
take the product over all of your
contours Z to some surface energy and
then inside you now have some new terms
which need to draw a picture to explain
so when you do this Risa mayshen you
sort of recreate partition functions and
that's the weight that I need to write
next so I'm going to come back to this
formula in one second let me just draw
the picture first and we have even
boundary conditions let's think about
this picture so I fix all the external
contours and I sum over all the possible
ways that I can get them what I see then
is again my same two so the difference
between these pictures is that since
I've summed over all possible
configurations there's many
possibilities in here now this is not
determined so this was an even boundary
condition so inside I actually see Z
partition function with even boundary
conditions in this region and here I see
a partition function with odd boundary
conditions so these contour objects
contain the partition functions in their
weight so they actually have a factor ze
so the the graph on which this partition
function lives is the interior of this
contour with label e so this could have
many components but I can still just
write the partition function as the
product so the partition functions
because they're in disjoint sets and I
also have to take the contribution from
all of the odd terms so good news this
is a polar model
so the notion of disjointness is just
that you fill in all the holes and you
check if the two things overlap and
that's the only thing you have to check
because everything is the same
exteriorly but before we celebrate too
much
the bad news is that how big are these
weights these weights are enormous right
they contain partition functions in them
that are like comparable to the volume
of the set so the weights are
exponentially large so if you wanted to
satisfy something like the Kotetsu key
price condition that we'll was using to
verify the convergence of the cluster
expansion there's no way it's going to
work in this representation and this is
the point where you really start to feel
the effect of having your favorite graph
BZD instead of the random regular graph
if you have expansion it doesn't matter
if it's experienced exponentially larger
than the volume the cost from the
boundary term is still going to let you
win on Z D that's just completely false
so I didn't say explicitly what this
factor is this just measures how many
particles are missing in the contour so
I'm trying to look at a densest possible
independent set so in any contour I'm
making mistakes because it's an
incorrect region so this just counts the
number of particles that are being
missed
[Music]
okay so we have a polymer model we can't
prove the cluster expansion converges so
what you do if you're someone who likes
expansion methods and you get stuck you
expand again this is somehow perhaps the
most important idea in doing well one of
the most important ideas in paragraphs
and AI theory which is sometimes called
the dilution trick and like any good
trick it looks very stupid so I can
rewrite the odd boundary partition
function in some region lambda so now
lambda is going to be like the interior
or some contour well it's that
multiplying by one this turns out to be
very good why is this good this term I
can expand again it's again a partition
function with an even boundary condition
so I just repeat and this term I absorb
into the weight of my contours my
polymers so if you expand the e terms
and you do this repeatedly what you get
is the following formula well it's going
to be a sum over collections of polymers
gamma that are mutually disjoint with
exterior label e because I expanded this
term again then I get a product over all
of the polymers a weight of the polymer
and what is that weight well it's like
the one I had before except now I have
to include this ratio of partition
functions
so it's the the number of missing
particles in the contour itself and then
a ratio of partition functions I have to
look at the interior regions with label
odd and take this ratio so I look at
that region that has odd boundary
condition I switch its boundary
condition to E and that's the term I
divide by okay so this is this is an
identity now I have another
representation for my partition function
this is another polymer model this one
is much better so why is this one much
better well I no longer have these
volume factors corresponding to the
interior so I could hope that my weights
are going to be small so for this
polymer model
you can prove Kotetsu key prices
satisfied
it lambdas very large or in our current
notation if Z is very small this is not
a trivial thing to do though the weights
that we saw in earlier tux today we're
mostly relatively simple combinatorial
things and now I have rather unpleasant
rational functions in my weights so I
don't really have time to go into how
you prove this convergence but the idea
is that you induct on volume and maybe
to give you some idea of why this should
be a good idea consider a really small
polymer like maybe it just has two
vertices in it there's no way there can
be an interior so this ratio is one so
then you have good control by making Z
small enough once you do that you look
at contours of size 1 bigger any of
their interior components can only
contain smaller contours and you already
understand smaller contours by induction
so you can control this ratio by using
the cluster expansion which you know
applies because they only contain small
contours
did you use the C to the D actually
doesn't expand contrary to what
beautiful yeah so you need some ISO
perimetry problems properties working
down the way right working the other way
so it's some of that confusion might be
resolved by saying that the notion of
ground state that I defined is not even
so good when you don't have any ISO
perigee
okay so that's how you prove that you
have the Kotetsu key price condition so
you have a convergent cluster expansion
so you can pretty much just use the
algorithms that will describe this
morning to prove the theorem just the
one thing that you need to remark is
that these weight functions are no
longer so obvious that you can compute
them efficiently so that was part of
wills algorithm was that you know that
you can compute weights efficiently so
to compute weight sufficiently all right
well you you draw inspiration from this
you sort of do it inductively I can
compute the weight of small contours
because this ratio is 1 and when I want
to compute the rate the weights later I
can get very good approximations to both
of these partition functions so I can
get very good approximations to these
weights and that's enough to make the
algorithm work that we'll described it's
not exactly the way he said it but it
does work
okay so that's how the proof of the
theorem that I've erased goes at least
in the case of subsets of ZD you have to
do something a little different on the
torus but it's an idea that you've now
seen three times this morning the idea
on the torus is the idea in the previous
talks was that if you want to look at
the Potts model partition function on a
random regular graph you break it into
the mostly red piece the mostly green
piece the mostly blue piece and so on
and on the torus here you just want to
break it into the mostly even piece and
the mostly odd piece and the way you can
do it is sort of say look at any
configuration with an enormous contour
and you can just prove by brute force
that this is unlikely if there's no
really big contours then you can sort of
embed your problem in ZD again and this
notion of an exterior contour makes
sense and you can develop all of the
same machinery and if you want to sample
it's again doing it contour by contour
so I should say that in this step there
there are relatively general theorems
that will do this step for you and for
example the one we used is do two boards
and Embree but in general you may have
to go into the guts of this for the
particular problem you're interested in
so I think that's the end of my time so
I'll stop here Thanks
[Applause]
so you begin by pointing out that in any
dimension my question is has a has the
dimension gets large I guess one company
knows that's so open actually but it's
believed to be I think someone over D or
log-log D over D but it's actually open
sort of region in which this expansion
converges how does that get farther away
from your people even higher dimensions
are closer it gets farther and really
much further this is like in that sense
it's a really unsatisfactory it sort of
a problem with the hard core model in
general is that we have no tools to sort
of show any kind of monotonicity so the
reason we don't know the exact rittle
point is sort of because we don't even
know that there's actually only two
regions there could be other phases in
between we don't even know how to prove
that that doesn't happen
such other question
in any of them
okay well let's in the morning session
and we come back at 2:15 so let's think
[Applause]